parce qu'on nous sommes en direct avec
notre envoyé spécial pauline godard à
qui l on va parler dans un instant d'une
autre une toute autre conférence de
presse qui vient de s'achever mais avant
cela
la question d'une étape ou non à kiev
elle est toujours posée même si emmanuel
macron a bien laissé comprendre qu'il y
avait une intention politique de
rencontrer les autorités ukrainiennes ça
fait des semaines des mois même que
volodymyr zelensky adressé à l'elysée
l'invitation doute pas qu'on l'attend de
pied ferme aujourd'hui
oui il est attendu en effet de pied
ferme mais pour l'instant aucune
confirmation officielle sur la venue des
mails des manuels macro même si en effet
tout laisse entendre que le chef de
l'état pourrait faire une étape à kiev
surtout que comme le disait karim c'est
très important et l'ukraine attend une
visite des manuels macron puisque
emmanuel macron est à la tête de la
présidence de l'union européenne la
france est à la tête de cette présidence
de l'union européenne les ukrainiens
espère donc emmanuel macron fera cette
étape et qu'il ne rentrera pas
directement en france après son étape et
sa visite en moldavie l'ukraine réclame
vous savez aux occidentaux quasi tous
les jours l'envoi de nouvelles a remis
hier la vice ministre de la défense
ukrainienne a encore expliqué que pour
le moment l'ukraine n'avait reçu que 10
% des armes qu'elle réclame aux
occidentaux on imagine que bien sûr ce
dossier sera sur la table si emmanuel
macron vient ici à kiev voilà peu une
godard vous avez suivi en parallèle pour
nous cet autre conférence de presse
dédiée celle de la commission d' enquête
de l'onu sur les crimes de guerre commis
en ukraine qu'est ce qu'on va en retenir
exactement
alors trois membres cette commission est
composée de trois membres les trois
membres se sont expliqués ils ont ils
ont expliqué avoir fait dix jours de
visite ils ont notamment rencontré la
procureure ukrainienne qui s'occupe ici
justement de récolter l'épreuve 1 contre
en ce qui concerne ces crimes de guerre
son sont rendus à kiev à bout de chahir
pin karkhiv est soumis ils ont rencontré
les autorités locales ils ont rencontré
également des ong ils ont recueilli des
témoignages ils l'ont dit et répété à
plusieurs reprises à ce stade nous ne
pouvons pas confirmer de façon
définitive quoi que ce soit mais
l'épreuve et ce qu'ils ont vu et entendu
pour le moment semble soutenir la thèse
que des violations du droit
international ont été commises des
violations des droits de l'homme ce qui
est très important pour eux ils l'ont
répété vraiment à de nombreuses reprises
ils ont assisté là dessus c'est de
collecter a des preuves sur des
potentiels crimes de guerre sur le
territoire ukrainien
nous n'avons que peu de preuves pour le
moment et nous devons y aller étape par
étape ils veulent accumuler le plus de
preuves possibles pour pouvoir présenter
un dossier solide un dossier très solide
irréprochable pour qu'ensuite et bien ce
dossier puisse être transmis à une
instance juridique aboud cherpines la
commission a fait état par rapport à ce
qu'elle a pu constater en effet de
destruction elle se dit concernée par
ces nombreuses
allégations qui en fait sur deux
possibles de potentielles violations du
droit des droits de l'homme et notamment
par rapport aux enfants ils continuent à
collecter ses preuves et ils ont
expliqué avoir une de nombreux
témoignages aussi d'enfants qui avait
disparu il est difficile de savoir pour
le moment où se trouvent ses enfants
certains se trouve sans doute dans les
territoires occupés par les russes avec
lesquels pour l'instant il est
impossible d'entrer en contact voilà
pourquoi la commission a dit qu'elle
voulait rentrer en contact avec les
autorités russes ils ont expliqué avoir
rencontré une délégation à genève mais
que pour le moment cela n'avait rien
donné ils ont également expliqué que
pour l'instant encore une fois il
voulait y aller de façon prudente et
qu'ils allaient rendre compte et bien de
tout ce qu'ils avaient vu à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies tout cela
aura lieu au mois de septembre et ils
ont confirmé qu'ils reviendraient
évidemment ici à kiev et en ukraine pour
continuer à collecter des preuves merci
beaucoup pauline de l'art en direct